josh is with us in Virginia hey Josh how
are you yeah oh you done better than I
deserve how can I help
uh we've got twins on the way right now
on top of three boys actually so oh do
you know do you know what you're having
yep two girls this is wonderful I love
it congratulations
thank you but our predicament I guess
you'd say is that's actually a blessing
our mother-in-law has a house that she
doesn't live in doesn't use and we're in
debt on our house and on two cars and
she said basically you got two kids two
more kids coming why don't you just take
this house sell your house and hopefully
that'll be enough to pay off your cars
and you can beat that free and just move
into the house a town but my question is
how do we do that
if and transfer them to our name and
then maybe here in ten years we decided
to move we go to sell the house we don't
want to pay a ton of taxes on capital
gain taxes okay so she's gonna she's
gonna give you the house free yes she
just said you decided what is the house
worth it's all probably thirty acres so
I'd say it's probably worth probably 400
thousand probably good gracious
so she's wealthy yes she swims her she
wasn't herded to her so okay but all
right here's the thing two things that
you need an ocean one is she needs to
see a tax attorney or an estate planning
attorney to do this properly otherwise
she's gonna have to pay gift tax on four
hundred thousand
which could be as much as a hundred
grand okay so she does this wrong it's
gonna really screw her up now you may
want to write this down which she needs
to ask the attorney about other is a
unified estate tax credit you know what
that means that unified like the
preacher said in now you're one unified
as state tax credit okay and what that
means is is that you're using up she
would be using up some of her federal
estate that passes tax-free at her death
she can use up some of it while she's
alive
okay and she's that way she could pass
this to you without any taxes but you've
got to file the paperwork otherwise the
IRS is going to come back or she's got a
filing they're gonna come back around
and hammer her and an audit so you can't
just hand somebody the keys to a four
hundred thousand dollar house without
getting screwed by your government okay
but so get some tax advice one number
two to answer your question your basis
for tax purposes becomes her basis her
basis was the value of the property at
the time she inherited it how long has
she had it she's had it her parents died
probably ten years ago so okay let's
just make up a number okay let's pretend
the house for the property was worth two
hundred thousand when she got it right
then that's what your basis is it's as
if you paid two hundred thousand for it
when she gifts it to you when someone
gives you something what they paid for
it becomes your basis now you can after
you've lived there two years it's your
primary residence and a married couple
filing jointly can earn up to five
hundred thousand above what they paid
for the property and have no taxes okay
and so if our example is right of two
hundred thousand is her basis you could
sell the property up to seven hundred
thousand was zero taxes okay so you're
probably never gonna pay taxes on this
okay so we're not in as much trouble as
what I was thinking we're gonna be in
and if you did I so let's say
thousand of it was taxable or something
that you went a hundred over that or
something it's at 15% so be 15 grand
it's not gonna kill you it's not gonna
kill you all right so you're okay
she is not unless she files his
paperwork properties I was talking about
a while ago
right yeah wonderfully wonderfully
generous think now here's the thing dude
you when she does all this and you get
your butt out of debt you kid on a
budget and don't you go back and dad
don't you walk on a car lot unless you
got the money you hear me I hear you all
right dude you got too many mouths to
feed to screw this up a second time I'm
so proud for you guys well done I love
it